salut les p'tits potes aujourd'hui on
s'attaque à piéger laudun airbnb nous
avons pris une chambre pour un soir en
précisant qu'on serait 2 à y dormir mais
seulement un seul d'entre nous va
vraiment y dormir
l'autre va t il s'en rende compte steam
tout au fond
[Musique]
les mecs vous êtes bien en position
louis lauté parti a maintenant dix
minutes
il revient demain matin à 10 heures ce
qui nous laisse un petit peu moins de 16
heures pour mettre en place le piège
c'est parti ok jeff rejoint dans le van
cette pas trop ronfler mec est filmé la
[Musique]
clé les amis il est 4h30 du matin dustin
dirt comme un bébé
pour l'instant tout se passe comme prévu
plus que 6e en attente ils ne seront si
le piège à fonctionner après une nuit de
sommeil jeff rejoint enfin destine bien
dormi dans le lit juste à côté ligne à a
hâté congé phare est fait pas les cons
allez les mecs
il ne vous reste plus qu'à ranger pour
rendre l'appartement propres pour
l'autre il faut que tout soit les pièces
attention l'hôte est de retour c'est
maintenant que tout va se jouer
ça va bien dormi bonjour bien passée
c'était très bien comme expérience ça
marche grave c'est nickel c'est parfait
ok ça se déroule comme prévu c'est
parfait on avait presque personne n'a
dormi là
ne pas n'existe pas je je vais trouver
quelque chose ne paniquez pas les mecs
je sèche les mecs désolé
je sais ta cadets 1 comme quoi ça marche
toujours
oui dans tout ça comme quoi comme c'est
à peu près d'accord c'est lui yes
et ça c'est bien merci beaucoup de bien
c'est bien c'est pas ses propres
merci bonne journée un journal ou ouais
les mecs vous avez assuré il a tellement
pas saisi d'entourloupe et ouais tu
croyais quoi tu as à faire un des
champions des champions du dodo ray et
c'est une mission accomplie pour la team
fou
encore une fois tout le monde n'y a vu
que du feu quoi
justin bieber est en fait un truc c'est
qu'il y en a qu un cadeau remis dans
l'appartement et alors quoi
[Musique]
vous m'avez lu oui oh la la oh là là non
huit critiques j'ai comme l'impression
que vous avez pris votre pied des mecs
alors abonnez vous et rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour des caméras
cachées encore plus fun
[Musique]